[Music]
let's talk about Snow White and the
Huntsman I have to ask you about this
this also another huge success you have
all these battle scenes where you're
riding a horse
are you naturally good on a horse did
you have to learn to ride the horse not
really no I mean I hate Tony ever sort
of on films and things but then you know
for the spice of a week or something and
we had the air we had big battle
sequences across you know the beach and
and storming the castle there were like
a hundred horse and what-have-you and
I'm in a number time my horse is doing
360s and you know going backwards and
it's I had this the Spanish horse when
it come up and slap the horse and it to
be like you know and it wasn't like an
abusive but here this kind of thing and
anyone who said just before this Taiki
said I can this chain right into the
into the courtyard of the castle
everyone's following flip your leg over
and just jump off the horse with with
the axe and the knife and the other and
the shield and the Seven weapons you've
got they say that that casually that
casually I said waiting rehearses and
things are on fire and blowing up and
sure enough in we charge with you never
and behind this right leg off foot still
in the stirrups faceplant
and the guys behind me jump off my end
on top of me and then as you know the
Queen's up in the castle incredibly
intimidated huge it's just your pride
more than anything absolutely well we
have a clip here from Snow White and
Huntsman what do we need to know for
this okay so the my character is the
kind of mercenaries that mr. drunken he
um he's recruited by the Queen to go out
and capture its know what and he's
offered something in return so he does
and and then he realizes that what he
was offered these not gonna get back so
this is what happens good set up sort of
this clip from snow way my big birthday
quick work
great well done Huntsman and ER ever
what do you intend to do with them why
do you care you want to hang you do what
I was promised you did your job well now
keep your word Oh
[Music]
[Applause]